what's going on there's citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the bad batch episode
11. look even though we weren't big fans of the
last couple episodes we always go in with an
optimistic attitude are we gonna get Cody are we
gonna get rex on you doesn't matter look we just
want enjoyable Star Wars and I feel like you know
what last few episodes I believe in the force so
I am alone with the force and the Force is with
me um yes Jackie Chan said that yeah sure did
um guys listen if you like satirical racism
jokes be sure to subscribe also leave a
like today that would be amazing follow my dewy
friend here Michael tesler uh on multi-house.io
and let's let's there's a patreon
but who cares let's just watch this
Dewey it's my favorite Star Wars character
it's not hard to imagine Harrison
Ford's saying that either
Harrison Ford was a carpenter yes he was
just like Jesus I remember Jason segelberg
give him some audio to sync
what are they retrieving unless you we're still
here on board I'm watching the wrong episode
I was like what the [__] [Laughter]
I've never seen that before
Adam metamorphosis good title
it's a lot of syllables oh [Music]
kinda looks carillion
foreign
spooky yeah I like this ready for Sigourney
Weaver to pop out yeah oh Republic Commando okay
[Music]
I wonder if it's like a Jedi or something
nope I don't think so man I'm not a Jedi
[Applause]
wow yeah it is pure alien yeah
Sigourney Weaver was actually in the suit
name it prove yourself I believe we might be
going to the Clone facilities welcome doctor
all preparations have been made for your arrival
have the cargo taken below the cargo Ellie [Music]
yeah we're we're tying right into the Mandalorian
here didn't they go here in season two foreign
[Music]
destroyed my civilization excuses
know that your research remains intact
it'll now serve a higher purpose
the emperor's purpose his voice is so familiar
know that I'll be taking over operations here on
Tantus and I can do far worse than confine you to
a cell tickle you to death that would do it for me
interesting prime minister he remains an imperial
custody on Coruscant here I wish to speak to him
personally cargo asset two things they refer
to when talking about grogu in season one of
Mandalorian oh my gosh is grogu the monster in
this [__] I got a tip on a down ship which means
cargo ripe for the taking I'll even give you 30
to the cut that is our standard percentage hahaha
okay 40. fine 50 as a token of my Goodwill that
you seem to have forgotten such a pain in the ass
what makes you think we'd come back at all
don't test me bandanna just get it done
God could be problematic considering what she
knows about us choose a diplomatic solution
this one last mission for her or a killer but
actually and spun Dakota indication of what
caused it to crash limited Intel there's a
surprise how hard could scavenger cargo be
oh my God what if the bad
batch is what helps Kroger
Escape what do you mean well we're still trying
to figure out how did grogu I mean somebody well
I'm just saying we're in the right we have all
the right pieces let's see what the share says
before we get too excited here the crashed
vessel appears mostly intact the cargo aboard
should be in fair enough condition to transport
[Music] but it would be cool thank you just say
it would be cool but the crew aboard most
likely perished we don't know for sure it
could be treasure in here
wow this is straight up the
aliens episode where is everyone
Zillow Beast something oh unfortunate
happened here it doesn't look like Roku
word kind of clone a Zillow beast and clone
wars and it's not warranted I will be fine
oh I like this it's like Nerf
nuggets it'd be cool if you're right
[Music] yeah that was Palpatine's
last order on Coruscant
[Music]
wreck those thighs you're at the gym
why is it so cold in here it's some kind of
Suicide Squad Tech find anything on the
bridge still rerouting the reserve power
stand by the grid should be restored
the mentality a bad feeling about this
oh that's a cool shot damn now they
pull that off that's a second rich
what were they keeping in here oh it's the
Zillow Beast you think so for sure yeah
Palpatine requested and make a clone of it
[Laughter]
is back away slowly
I'm still waiting for a clearer shot
Michael's skin hahaha I hope
oh it's so cute I love it
it's like when there's a demogorgon then there's
a demo dog you know that's exactly it
it's a little baby I love this episode
it's good thing all these lights are on
I suspect this is some type of research
vessel we know and whatever researching
just got loose and it's headed your
way whoa what if they kill off Tech
I've been saying it all season
oh
oh it's creepy man say I love that it eats
electricity oh it makes it stronger yeah
still not gonna do it not even close
damn oh it's on the loose we have to
neutralize it before it hurts anyone how
given the fact that the crew was most likely
eaten by the creature I doubt it is currently
[Music]
love that reaction I can help I
know my way around kamino and tea go
go Rebecca me you guys Gotta Be Heroes I
mean like they still haven't explicitly
said it and it would be a very baby little
one but that makes sense with how much time
they've had to grow it yeah no I think you're
right sure there's a great payoff to that one
episode when people thought that would be
the zoo yeah definitively not yeah [Music]
[Music]
oh man
no I mean it took like half of the Jedi
Grand Council that was much more developed
yep that's my feelings
it's me at the snack bar it was unaffected by
our Blaster fire this confirms that the species
feeds on energy which propels its rapid growth you
mean it'll get even bigger oh yeah creature is the
must not let it get near the power grid or
it will increase color what it is say it
this poor Planet it's like a combo there of
Godzilla and Kong uh I'm so ready for this
damn is it all coming back to the Zillow Beast
it's all connected Greg no I mean like
the the Empire's showing up you know
well they're clearly here
to protect the citizens yes
come on come on now and
so are those Imperial gunships
now is that the phrase
oh man oh man you guys gotta stab it
[Music] oh oh look at Tech protecting her
oh yeah good luck
tractor beam tractor
you guys not attracted me okay now
it's they use the Cannons previously
to get it off planet to Coruscant yes
you need a lot more of those though
or not I guess they're upgraded
the clock it's a Pixar reference
it's taking it let's not be next [Music]
we gotta draw the empire into the city then
we can escape well they gotta get techno Mega
be calm we're here to protect you we're
with the government and we're here to help
[Music]
going on a roller coaster [Music]
sometimes when you jump to light speed
terrifying
[Music] oh yeah you saw too much [Music]
cat the Empire sucks I know
but he had a business to run
it's good to see both sides you know vessel was
part of an imperial cloning operation the Empire
cloned the Zillow Beast yes and finally said I
suspect the empire did not destroy the city's
El Camino to end cloning they merely wanted to
control it hmm yes move everything send the data
to Echo and Rex see what they can find out ah it's
all coming together Rex gonna have a field there
Echo oh yeah I'm over that yeah we're
cool we're cool again no harm no foul yeah
the creature has been recovered
and is now safely secured below
good and our other guest the shuttle is arriving
now the Prime Minister the cooperation of your
Chief scientist has not been forthcoming it must
be frustrating to have your resources but lack the
expertise to achieve your goals you're telling me
I fear you misunderstand your situation here there
is a particular clone you must locate a young girl
oh the key to controlling how very interesting it
discuss good thing they're
looking for that ship man
where's Benny [Laughter]
okay okay that was great so
glad Zillow Beast is back uh
so glad that all this cleaning stuff is
getting tied in together I mean this is
like a perfect uh through line to the
Mandalorian and then subsequently the
creation of snoke and subsequently the creation
of Palpatine 2.0 you could call it that it's like
0.3 the one from Rise of Skywalker yeah yeah he's
great yeah it's great my favorite Palpatine them
all in inmate his best interpretation
of the character uh yeah yeah somehow
Palpatine returned and now we know that it's
all Omega the dead speaks the dead speak uh
okay okay so yeah they gotta get Omega then yeah
considering the progress that we know of the
future of how things progress unless of course now
let's say comes in and it's like there's another
way to achieve your goals that does not involve
Omega which would be boring that would be really
boring yeah no they have to go after Omega um
but this the Zillow Beast has never come back
in other things right no not yet um no I
mean I think all of this it plays into the
larger like if there is which I'm uh showrunners
Catherine Kennedy have said there is a cinematic
climactic event that we're working towards
right now um and this is they also mentioned
that Mandalorian season four is going to
be actually a middle chapter of something
bigger yes uh which like as we play into the
thrawn Ahsoka you know that whole careless
who gives a [__] about it I love it's okay
boring Bridger is a wonderful Ezra Miller is
a fantastic actor yeah I agree I think having
I think Ezra Miller playing Ezra pressure was
the right choice yeah I was surprised including
the Clone version of Ezra there's three of them
let's keep it on track yeah yeah no no I think
yeah I think you're right about all that and I
but more importantly more than what it ties into
more than what it connects it was actually just
a good episode it was a solid episode it had
a great spooky sense I feel like every sci-fi
thing I ever watched at one point or another
will have an inevitable episode in a season
that goes this is like alien this is like the
Alien movies yeah those were good and full of
dread that's spooky ominous Horror in there and
it's it's apt when it comes to the Zillow Beast
uh something that I I've never I've only
seen Clone Wars once but so and that was a
little long time ago yeah I I just finished
the fourth time around yeah good call good
call yeah no I'm really glad uh it's paid off
I had that feeling with Zillow beasts of after
people thought it was that one creature in that
Planet episode Legend of Zelda looking like yeah
people thought that was a civil obese and uh
so after it wasn't I went all right I'm gonna
write off a Zillow Beast returning completely so
I didn't even answer my Noggin however the way it
came back I thought it was really suspenseful
yeah and spooky and the way they would always
check in with it and watching it grow and how
it also Rift not just on alien but like Kaiju
movies you know I was gonna say that was I mean I
feel like Star Wars particularly animated content
does best when it pays not so subtle uh homages
to some other great works of art uh you know and
I guess Star Wars in general I mean it's just
like let's take Samurai movies and westerns and
put them in space yeah um you know so yeah so
that was a really it was just a fun episode I
felt like you know uh for the 40th time both of us
were really worried that Tech was gonna get killed
um he's great which uh yeah which means you know
they've they've set the stakes where we need them
um now I'm really interested to see how they're
gonna start working towards the closure of this
season part of me wonders if it's gonna end
and with uh Omega getting taken and the bad
batch needing to work with our friends in the
Clone Rebellion to try to break Omega out and to
take those two story lines and put them together
we'll see that's my theory what do you think Greg
uh I think that she will get taken I don't think
it will end that way even though the show would be
smart to do that that way we better get another
season that way he can't be full to go I guess
I'll watch season threes so yeah I think it would
be be a smart way but I think they would want to
bring some time I think it'll be a little bit more
I feel like though yeah Omega will be taken off
the rest of her Tech's gonna cry the Tech's gonna
be like no I have learned to love you Omega I care
more about you than I ever realized it's gonna be
brilliant mark my words Crosshair is going to be
the one to save Omega um words have been marked
I think they've cut them out of the show they had
one episode mark my words either that or Hondo
they're gonna I think what they will end this
season with is a tease to whatever the bigger
thing is that they're building too as alluded
already with Mandalorian season four offering up
some middle chapter to something bigger so I think
that's what they'll end with yeah um but as far as
as far as uh I was I was just happy that we got a
good bad job I agree do you think final question
there is any like direct seeing of grogu no I
mean we're we're dealing with the cloning facility
like we're we're seeing the origins of of all that
stuff in the Mandalore you doubt it doubt it I
mean when you look at the beginning of where Mando
started uh I think we don't know how grogu ended
up where he was but yeah you know I think they
would have already have had they wouldn't have
just lost him into possession they wanted to pull
up metichlorians out of him right yeah is that
what they want to do yeah they want the MCAT yeah
um yeah I love that medical orients this thing
that so many of us Star Wars fans pushed against
is now the soul creative tissue commit to
the bit all right yeah it's good number one
no I mean yeah grogu definitively I don't
think the Empire had him in their control
um I think they managed to locate him somehow
yeah and I want to know how yeah and I I just
I think it would be really neat if whether
through the cloned Rebellion or through you
know any one of these um I wonder if there's
connective thread because we still don't know
I'm also really interested to see if Jedi
Survivor is connected to this um because
there are some questions strong cloning I mean
the fella in the back to tank in the trailer
um I'm just I have so many questions uh and
hey that means they're doing a good job so
yeah they've won you back over yeah I mean I was
never not sold Greg I love that I just had two
episodes that were you're a big fan of it's fine
it was they're allowed to have two not perfect
episodes and they brought it back home yeah they
brought it back home and next week we're gonna
find treasure have we hey and they wanted to get
rid of Sid we didn't even talk about that that's
a really important I hope they do they were like
one Mission and then we're out and I appreciate
that the writers figured out how annoying Sid
was and then came up with a a narrative reason
that they're worried that Sid would turn on
them and give up their yeah to the which is
so fair to justify why they would still kick
it with her yeah again I liked your idea though
just kill her just kill her I think that would
be great then you could do season three the evil
batch yeah what did you guys think I would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments I will respond
I do want room one thing I have to say yeah the
the the doctor yeah I don't know who this voice
actor was I played him how have we seen him
before you know I was trying to figure that
out because he said he's Hemlock was it yeah I
think so yeah it's such a striking presence yeah
it wasn't really striking presence I mean I think
and we're more than likely going to see a young
an intern version of uh what's his name uh Dr
Pershing Pershing yeah yeah uh from Mandalorian
um yeah that's that's what I was hoping for and
then I was doing math in my head and I was like
all right I see why um but yeah no it it's um
I I didn't recognize him uh but that doesn't
mean he hasn't shown up in a book or something
yeah I like them a lot I think I like the more
soft-spoken sincere the ones where they don't
play it evil like yeah I could see you pal
people would trust you yeah I feel like that's
just an issue with the empire in general which
is what I like about this whole sub plot that's
going on is sure this is almost more nefarious
and more interesting and and I think just like
bring back like the former prime minister whose
people were all annihilated and then just like I
love what they're doing um oh one more thing um
every pixel might Baker I want to get to
know you better for 2023 yeah so I'm gonna
ask you five questions and I want you to give
five sentences only you cannot give more than
that yeah and I want you to answer me this one
how many serious relationships have you been in
yeah and like serious like you know could it be
the one yeah good good emphasis two if you were
to be a donut which donut would you prefer to
be three and and that just has it whatever your
choice is we understand it has nothing to do with
your sexuality just like I appreciate emphasis
three if you saw the ending of the movie sausage
party would you have participated as a human being
with the food four yeah that's an easy answer yeah
yeah I'll judge you if you give the wrong one four
um what religion do you belong to and which
religion do you really not like and five
do you prefer Jeremy johns or Chris stuckman
for the religion one good question
thanks for being here Everett we love you Everett
thank you for your support [Music] foreign